[Musique]
en plein quartier industriel de brossard
ferme divers produits une tonnes de
fraises pour le temps des fêtes
son unité laboratoire est situé dans un
entrepôt sans aucune fenêtre
on recrée la nature on recrée les
éléments nécessaires pour que les
plantes les volubiles
on a beaucoup de lumière pour sa part
d'énergie ces plantes leur ca prends les
mêmes principes que la production ce
qu'on appelle la production hors sol la
production en serre on a les mêmes des
lots on a le même terreau on a les mêmes
plein le même système d'irrigation
c'est quoi la différence c'est la
superposition c'est que le soleil d'une
serre arrive par an aux nouvelles le
soleil est en face ça qu'on est capable
comme ici à 6,30 fraises dans une salle
jean-nohain que vous avez plus chaud
bouchard que l'autre côté laissant
seulement vous n'avez pas pu avoir ça le
système assure aussi une température et
une humidité constante ce qui augmente
la production donc on peut une carte on
travaille on peut éloigner le soleil
entre guillemets leur espace de regarder
tout ce qu'on a comme comme dans le fond
comme phrase il y en a partout
ce sont les accueilli hier ses phrases
heures il y en a en quantité
industrielle
la culture vertical comme on le propose
permet de faire une production de fonds
sans aucun pesticide qui ont aucun aucun
traitement pour altérer la saveur
enfants
la plancha s'exprimer en plus de
produire des fraises l'installation
permet de chauffer des serres adjacentes
en récupérant la chaleur de l'éclairage
pour chaque pied carré de fraises on va
chauffer trop à quatre pieds carrés de
salles panda culture confère à faire
parce que ça faisait si j'ai dit à mes
pieds carrés je vous chauffez 30000
picard et de production de poivrons de
production de tomates de production de
concombres
une installation 12 fois plus grands on
est en construction à vaudreuil il des
ententes ont été signées avec une
dizaine d'autres producteurs
on reçoit tous les jours deux à trois
appels de maraîchers pourquoi pas savoir
changer leur vie un peu c'est payant
pour lui de produire de la france pour
nous deux ce qui lui permet de fédérer
des coûts sur 12 mois et 3,20 et la
demande du produit local et je sens
croissance ferme divers prévoit
construire quatre unités de 1000 m² par
annie à 4 millions de dollars chacune
elle assume le tiers des coûts et le
producteur maraîcher les deux tiers puis
toute la production est déjà vendue à
iga ce qu'on veut faire c'est de semer
des fermes un peu partout au québec est
d'être capable moi mon rêve là aussi
c'est d'être un art nador le producteur
à la frontière américaine
j'ai commencé à être dans le fond le
producteur maraîcher du nord de
l'amérique durant les hors saison
officielle pour qu'on puisse vraiment
développer une économie pauvre en deux
ligues distribue et vend des produits
finis avec cet électeur celles
auxquelles j'appartiens à tous ici marie
claude morin radio-canada à brossard
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit